[Musique]
vous
commençant au moins en 2002 et se poursuivant
jusqu'en 2005, Epstein aurait
abusé de dizaines de victimes en les obligeant
à se livrer à des actes sexuels avec lui dans son
manoir à New York et dans son domaine à
Palm Beach en Floride cette conduite  comme
allégué a duré des années et a impliqué
des dizaines de jeunes filles dont certaines n'avaient que
14 ans au moment où elles auraient été
maltraitées
[Musique]
et bien que la conduite de l'accusation date d'il y a
plusieurs années, elle est toujours
profondément importante pour les nombreux
victimes présumées maintenant jeunes femmes, elles méritent
leur journée au tribunal, nous sommes fiers de les
défendre en vous apportant cet
acte d'accusation
[Musique]